[Musica]
rilassatevi ragazzi perché oggi nostro
fa vj insegna le buone maniere
avete mai avuto un appuntamento
romantico ecco neanche io
sappiate che c'è sempre modo di stupire
la persona che avete di fronte perché in
questo gioco noi impareremo a
comportarci a tavola allora innanzitutto
muoviamo la mano prendiamo le robe e
versiamo dentro no ok a posto perfetto
questo tutorial immagino senza persona
vedi che si può muovere la mano che
avrebbe fin qua c'è rogo today dating
artshot inter ok posso fare dating
allora benissimo
enjoy walks no non mi piace non mi piace
ma cercando la persona giusta per
portarvi da qualche parte divertirmi lei
sgrosso sica ma ogni piacere mi chiamo
lorenzo sono don giovanni che new light
da quando poi da poi accendere la
candela dove non solo accendino tesoro
parte che sta bistecca mi sembra una
sola di scarpato portata da bistecche di
match.com come si fa da tempo devo farlo
pure ho capito come faccio
non ho un accendino a noi qua solo se i
fiammiferi arrivo no no tesoro mangiato
sono a dieta no che dai fuoco no ok
perfetto
ok mi sembra puntata di space valley ok
meraviglio tesoro la senso wine
certo ci mancherebbe a scusa e niente
volevo metterci il fiammifero nel vino
ma occhio che vai a fuoco nel senso che
6 ott
nel senso che fai tu allora il vino way
la sec che riguarda un prototipo
meraviglioso non si riempie bicchiere
eccolo qua meno verso solo io e tu che
fai
le patatine hanno bisogno di sale puoi
darmi una mano
tutte e due amica milano è nata non solo
una questa e pepe quindi nella bistecca
p bistecca pepe pepe nella viste
c'è un po di bistecca in questo pezzo è
fantastico e poi il sun no scusa aveva
angelo con la bistecca il tubetto mi
servirebbe il sale ecco che riguarda il
tipo mamma
gli armenti limone ray anche io tesoro
mazzanti miracoli fa timber ok
eccolo perfetti realtà l'ho messo sul
secchio mangiati secchio ma basta a
fatti le cose la sola che palle dove
dove lo devo mettere solo non capito nel
piatto nel piatto fermati perché farò
con la faccia schifata mi sto impegnando
una scusami non viene a devo devo scuote
lo tipo eccolo eccolo meraviglioso e lo
sto facendo non va è perfetto da iem son
brownies sì ma mi hai preso per il tuo
ragazzo per il cazzo di cameriere che
non ho capito des browne
eccoli i brownies togliti tutto bravo
c'erano qua alza il braccino tesoro ne
che lo fa tutto io nella vita però porco
le ma vabbè che sol uomo però madonna
aspetta che qua che i brownies romagna
dall'authority imbocco perché sei un
tesoro amore michela mano e cup by
signore quando volete quindi colmi ci
abbiamo fatto adesso passiamo allo step
2 o che lo step 2 con un'altra ragazza
sempre con quella solo quella
quindi tu puoi portarti una ragazza fino
alla fine ok ma sono curioso di vedere
l'ultimo che penso sia il sushi ma il
logo penso che le cose si faranno un po
più complicate adesso cosa vuoi una a
devo ordinarlo aspetta place a nord ok
adesso devo ordinare proprio le cose
quindi pam e ho capito e non lo so resto
preso le ho capito mi deve arrivare a ok
perfetto dove il manto rimb.off beers
no no stai tranquillo ma con questa qua
ci vado solo a cena no tesoro ordine
un'altra birra un attimo dal mio secondo
no ho capito ma perfetto tre birre
no perché ho poi farle cadere tutte e
tre quindi ecco già una infatti merico
fatto bene no e chi ha fatto benissimo
almeno nei tre ragazzi sono cascate sul
serio allora a posto tesoro come bevo io
non hai idea sono astemio proveniente
l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta in tempo ce l'ho fatta da
regalo directional nemmeno lo vedo
tesoro si parte da un giorno mangiare la
vera pizza a napoli che è sta roba che è
stato seri aqua poiché stanno i patavini
ovo ciak e poi ci sta a 3 in più e non
serve una sega però a ordiniamo tanto
pago io
porca troppo traparente allora la pizza
prendo un po difetta e prendi le
collette rimani la donna sta pizze pongo
lega pizza pongo e tv con le pizze finte
che dai ai cani come giocattolo o posto
a ne prendi altre donne o la dieta
proprio un altro giorno e facevamo nato
la birra sta continuando aversa si da
due ore minchia duras capire cosa è una
birra infinita e un loop infinito di
birra ma un'altra ancora
ma basta l'ho già ordinata regala al
pepe vuoi quel pepe sulla pizza ma tu
sei scema mi chiama cameriera il conto
per cortesia no ma fai uomini ma fai
schifo non ti meriti niente ici 6 25
ketchup no io te l'ho ma eccolo lì la
tua pizza impepata un attimo porco
demonio mi fai fare 20 con la birra
stanno arrivando a versarsi tieni per
prego una sola patatina e poi il sale il
sale sulla patatina singola eccolo qua
meraviglioso tesoro è quando vuoi
non posso dare fuoco alla candela zia ma
fuoco al tavolo va a fuoco il ok un
altro brown ivo che si fa di brown ima
che seguì brown i due cameriere venga
che la dieta la facciamo un altro giorno
perfetto tanto pago gli 8.000 euro sopra
lo stage era nel negozio top lo metto
più vicino ma che non lo vedi eccolo qua
chi devo imboccare perché non riesce a
mangiare eccomi qui
meraviglioso tesoro il cosa che sto
facendo nella mia vita io comunque vedi
che le donne vedete che comunque ha né
c'è mela campo per quattro fuori da rega
madonna sempre la stessa tv
sono tre volte riusciamo però è dato
fuoco la crème brulée il mio sogno più
ora se lo usavo di più qualcosa aprivo
un cavo però vabbè cos'è che vuoi lo
champagne e zia fantastico top pure lo
champagne e ragazze ho fatto da anche il
terzo sta andando benissimo ho fatto
solo dalla fine ma devo anche stapparlo
questo ko e come si stappa c'è una mano
sola ei occhio all'occhio
eccolo ho fatto anche il terzo adesso
andiamo teoricamente ci debba essere il
sushi
l'ho fatto con un tempo record tra
l'altro ovest colmi e sempre col mi è
sempre colmi non si fa niente credo la
freccia con sushi quindi teoricamente
qua siamo al top del top sembra lo
stesso bar sempre le stesse cose però il
tavolo un peso diverso questa volta devo
prendere quesito fare non ci sono non ci
sono fiammiferi e quindi devo quindi
dopo accendere quello con la fiamma e
quindi devo insegnare adesso per far le
cose mi sa perché ci sono cose ma non ci
sono oggetti allora innanzitutto per
accendere candele così ok quindi adesso
diventa più difficile che devi ingegnere
per farle robe si ordina sushi o no che
la vede con sushi hamburger
non vedo sushi per adesso hamburger
patatine hamburger padalino innanzitutto
tutte voi un ragazzo tale tavolo
aiuto aiuto aspetta aspetta va a fuoco
va a fuoco il tavolo mannaia la morte
eccolo a posto risolto niente hamburger
tu tieni eccolo qui questo il tuo
hamburger perfetto e prendiamo lei li i
cosi le patatine che lo prese qua
aspetta ecco qua manca il pomodoro però
in tutto sto casino non so dove sia
bello mi piace che sia una ragazza
indipendente funziona sta roba
dove sono i pomodori ma non li posso
neanche ordinare sono finiti
non li posso ordinare il mondo sono
finiti pomodori e quindi allora aspetta
mi devo insegnare per fare l'europa che
non ci sono i cosi allora devo ordinare
una tra hamburger e dati da mangiare più
del pomodoro ed hamburger porco del
demonio miss e bancata a mano emanuela
dai però dato batte rosato non
agganciato mannaia business mission
catch up pure ma cribbio
toh cosa guardi telefono brutta astra
cosa sta succedendo ti sto dando
fastidio per caso questa cosa ti dà
sistemando fastidio per caso questo
appuntamento avresti preferito non farlo
neanche io addrizza bicchiere te lo
metto qui più che metterlo dentro
nel senso vanno a maroni in quel senso
nel senso del bicchiere nel senso del
bicchiere mettertelo dentro bicchiere il
big il whisky mauro ancora scegliamo un
prossimo episodio nel prossimo episodio
facciamo di più
ok da ragazzi
[Musica]